♪ ("SMALL CAR"
BY MARVIN PONTIAC PLAYS) ♪
♪ This is a story
About a place ♪
♪ Very, very, very far away
From here ♪
♪ Where tiny little farmers
Live with their families ♪
♪ And small, one inch long
Barking dogs ♪
♪ And they make their cars
Out of cans ♪
♪ In a car, in a car
In a small car ♪
♪ In a small car
In a car, in a small car ♪
♪ In a small car driving ♪
♪ These farmers thought
That there must be a way ♪
♪ To know why the stars
Are shining ♪
♪ And they wanted to see
And they decided to go ♪
♪ On a mission ♪
♪ In a car, in a car
In a small car ♪
♪ In a small car
In a car, in a small car ♪
♪ In a small car driving ♪
♪ So they decided to go
For a ride ♪
♪ And they drove
On the highway ♪
♪ They drove on the highways
Past the armadillos ♪
♪ Like the armadillos
In Switzerland ♪
♪ And they said
"Oh, it is so beautiful" ♪
♪ In a car, in a car
In a small car ♪
♪ In a small car
In a car, in a small car ♪
♪ In a small car driving ♪
♪ And as they drove, they looked
From car to car ♪
♪ Smiling at each other
As they drove ♪
♪ Past each other as they
Drove past each other ♪
♪ And they smiled and they said
"Hello, farmer" ♪
♪ They said hello to each other
♪ Hello, farmer, hello ♪
♪ Hello, farmer
Hello, farmer, hello ♪
♪ In a car, in a car
In a small car ♪
♪ In a small car
In a car, in a small car ♪
♪ In a small car driving ♪
♪ And there were birds
Flying in the sky ♪
♪ And the farmers looked up
and pointed at the birds ♪
♪ And said look
Look ♪
♪ And the birds flowed
And swooped down on the cars ♪
♪ In a friendly fashion ♪
♪ In a car, in a car
In a small car ♪
♪ In a small car
In a car, in a small car ♪
♪ In a small car driving ♪
♪ And finally, the farmers
Reached a place ♪
♪ Where the people were much
Much bigger than they were ♪
♪ These people were actually
Normal size as we know them ♪
♪ They did not make their cars
Out of cans ♪
♪ But they made their cars
out of metal ♪
♪ And they used cans as cans ♪
♪ And these people were giants
To the farmers ♪
♪ And they had some fear ♪
♪ But they were strong and noble
These farmers ♪
♪ They decided
That they did not belong here ♪
♪ And this was not
A good place for them ♪
♪ In a car, in a car
In a small car ♪
♪ In a small car
In a car, in a small car ♪
♪ In a small car driving ♪
♪ And so they turned around
And they drove home ♪
♪ But they had a nice day ♪
♪ They had had a nice day ♪
♪ In a car, in a car
In a small car ♪
♪ In a small car
In a car, in a small car ♪
♪ In a small car driving ♪
♪ And they arrived home
And they got out of their cars ♪
♪ And the husbands and the wives
Smiled at each other ♪
♪ And the children played
In the yard ♪
♪ But they still 'til this day
They remember the time ♪
♪ When they all went out ♪
♪ In a car, in a car
In a small car ♪
♪ In a small car
In a car, in a small car ♪
♪ In a small car driving ♪
♪ In a car, in a car
In a small car ♪
♪ In a small car
In a car, in a small car ♪
♪ In a small car driving ♪
♪ In a car, in a car
In a small car ♪
♪ In a small car
In a car, in a small car ♪
♪ In a small car driving ♪
♪ (MUSIC FADES) ♪